- [Narrator] Almost no other
predator on the planet inspires
as much terror
and curiosity as the python.
One of the world's longest
snakes is a python.
The reticulated python of Southeast Asia
usually grows around 16 feet long.
However, the current record
holder for the longest
reticulated python measured at 25 feet.
Pythons' long bodies
help the reptiles kill
by way of constriction.
They wrap their bodies around
prey and every time the prey
exhales, the python squeezes more tightly.
This disrupts the prey's
respiration and blood flow
inevitably leading to its death.
Pythons have legs.
Called spurs, these two
limbs appear as small bumps
on the sides of a python's pelvis.
While too small for locomotive function,
the spurs and pelvis are remnants
of pythons' evolution from lizards.
This evolution occurred
around 100 million years ago.
One possible early ancestor of pythons
called the tetrapodophis
was a fusion of lizard
and snake-like features and had hind legs.
Interestingly, scientists
found that pythons had retained
the genetic mutation for growing limbs.
This means pythons may be capable
of having fully functional
legs once again.
Pythons do not unhinge
their jaws when they eat.
Contrary to popular belief,
pythons cannot unhinge their jaws.
Rather, their jaws rest
on a multi-hinged joint
that provides for incredible flexibility
and enables the snakes
to devour large prey.
Flexibility is also aided
by pythons' lower right
and left jaw bones.
Unlike mammals which have
one solid lower jawbone,
pythons lower jaws are
made of two bones linked
by an elastic ligament.
This allows the bones to stretch
more widely to help swallow
prey at least two to three times wider
than the snake's head.
Pythons skulls can "walk" over prey.
Pythons have six rows of
teeth in their skulls.
Two in their lower jaws,
two in their upper jaws,
and two more in the roof of their mouth.
Through a phenomenon
called cranial kinesis,
or pterygoid walk, each
of these rows can be moved
independently which
allows snakes to drag prey
into their throats without
the use of front limbs.
Python teeth also help this process.
They're extremely sharp
and curve backwards.
Perfect for catching
and clinging onto prey.
Some pythons have become invasive species.
While native to the tropics of
Africa, Asia, and Australia,
several python species
have been transported
to the United States by
way of pet trafficking.
Florida's Everglades
National Park in particular
is home to tens of thousands
of invasive Burmese pythons.
Poor care, neglect, and accidents
have caused many pythons
originally taken in as pets
to kill native wildlife,
other pets, and even children.
But when left alone in
their natural habitat,
pythons are generally docile.
Pythons are some of nature's
most incredible predators.
Their long bodies,
constricting capabilities,
and skulls optimize for
devouring large prey
are enough to strike fear
(hissing)
and awe in anyone's heart.